哈囉大家好
歡迎來到周慕姿放心說
今天邀請的大來賓
是大象體操的凱婷
嗨
我要看哪裡啊
哈哈
你看這邊
剛剛我們有聊到
其實是臉友
嗯
對對對對
就是我們因為樂團的關係
所以
可能因為樂團
就是默默加了好友
然後彼此都知道彼此的樂團
但從來沒有見過面
對應該是沒有見過面
就只有我有看過你表演
然後可能有時候就是
說不定是在一些音樂季呀
大概
也許有錯身
然後我可能都是醉的
哈哈
認不出 不好說
哈哈哈哈
不好說
就是要不是在喝醉的路上
要不就是正在
就是倒在路上
對對對
然後我現在手上啊
有非常非常可愛的小禮物
這個聽說是
親友團才有
對不好意思
因為我個人就自肥了
我就得到了這個小禮物
就是你們團員的可愛小卡
對不對
而且還有你們
小時候的照片
對因為這次是紀錄片
所以想說讓
那個朋友們看看
我們小時候的樣子
真的這一部紀錄片
是比夢境更真實
然後這也是為什麼
可以有這個契機
邀請凱婷來上我們的節目
要訪問凱婷前
其實我已經先把那個紀錄片看完了
嗯謝謝你
對那這個紀錄片
其實會上映
上映資訊等一下我會放在資訊欄
等一下還會再講一次
但是我先講
嗯
那紀錄片真的超好看
真的嗎
而且我覺得因為有在玩樂團
特別有感就是那個
大家三個人坐在那邊要吵架
然後在那邊哭到
我就在那邊啊
你也有哭嗎
有啊
我就覺得我好能懂
那個瞬間就是說
就是啊我們
就是這個團到底
還要不要玩下去
嗯嗯
然後那個中間的很多困難
然後討論的時候會有很多不爽啊
或者是
然後或者是說
那個中間有人去玩別的團啊
然後很生氣這個
我就覺得超優秀
感覺在幫我罵他
沒有沒有沒有
我沒有這個意思哦
千萬不要這麼說
嘉欽是吧
哈哈
嘉欽我絕對沒有這個意思
我覺得
我覺得你真的是很辛苦
對真的很辛苦
對對對
所以我想要先跟就是凱婷問一下
就是
為什麼你們會就是想要
就是做這個紀錄片
好就是
因為剛剛木茲有提到就是
因為你有在玩樂團
所以你會知道
玩團的路上有很多艱辛
就不只是跟創作有關的
真的是
你們三個人或四個人
就有點像是在同一艘船上這樣
所以
那時候我們在推出這個紀錄片的時候
有在討論說
我們希望我們的TA就是是誰來看
我們其實超級希望是玩樂團的後輩
哦
就是
很希望是
還沒經歷或者是已經
剛開始要經歷這種
就是這麼強張力的
相處的人
可以先來
讓大象體操安慰你說
欸大家都是這樣哦
大家都是這樣過來的
嗯
對對對
然後
我們當初會想要做這個紀錄片
其實是凱翔
因為他是在大學的時候
就是念廣電系
然後從小的夢想是拍片
然後等到他真的去拍片之後
他就被那個
疲累的程度
嚇到退出
就是
對因為片場就是
要一直互等吧
然後
凱翔就是念書的時候很想拍片
然後想當導演
然後後來發現
他想要完成一個作品的話
他需要的團隊是非常大的
沒錯
然後要現場做的調度跟事前
還有後續的那些籌備
讓他覺得
他可能沒有辦法
做到這件事情
然後還有身心的狀況
所以他其實我們從大學就開始玩
大象體操這個團
嗯
然後他就轉而把他的
對於藝術創作的那個注意力
就放在音樂上面
所以我們就是跟他一起這樣
然後結果玩到現在也超過十年
然後他就開始一直默默的提說
欸我們可不可以來拍個紀錄片
哦
然後我跟嘉欽都沒有很想理他
因為拍紀錄片很
就是感覺就會隨時有攝影機
要跟在你旁邊
但是我們平常都是素顏
就是玩樂團的人都是
上臺最後前一刻才在化妝的人
對啊然後都很隨便啊
對然後
然後又要我們出國又要花錢請攝影師
去跟我們去美國什麼
很麻煩
然後結果凱翔就有一天就說
有臺藝大跟北藝大的電影系的
同學們他們畢業製作想要拍大象體操
願不願意讓他們拍
然後我那時候就想說
他一定有在盤算什麼事情
哈哈哈哈
結果果然他就是跟同學們說
沒問題你們任意拍免費拍
只是你們這些素材
要給我 我以後會
可能會拿來用哦這樣
然後結果就他們那時候就累積了
大量的素材包含你看到的那個
就是吵架的部分
對對對對對對
然後凱翔就
吵架你們也給拍欸
都給拍
太了不起了
對但是那時候就是
我印象很深刻的凱翔在
同學們真的要下高雄
紀錄我們的生活之前
他有問我
就可能因為我是女生吧
他就說
凱婷你有沒有什麼畫面或什麼樣子是
呃不想呈現在
螢幕上的
這樣就可以先跟同學溝通
然後我就想了一下
我就覺得
如果我真的設下什麼限制
那可能真的什麼都不能拍了
所以我到最後就是跟他們講說
你就隨便拍吧
哦
對所以
就是即使我們那個要吵架的
要開會啦
然後凱翔也是說
今天同學也會來拍攝
我其實那時候已經氣到不想理他
我就說哦好啊
隨便啦
哈哈哈哈
我就爛
哈哈
所以我在看的時候其實我覺得
我最感動的就是
那個吵架那個
但是我的確有講
因為你們那時候
對不起我們會破梗
但是這絕對不會影響各位的觀感
就是那個觀影體驗哦
因為你那個動力跟那個過程
還是只有看紀錄片才看得到
但是我那時候在看就是
就是你們三個在那邊
然後
凱翔真的就是團長
就是每一個團都一定要有這樣一個人
嗯
然後就是很機歪
然後就是規矩一大堆
然後一直訂計劃
然後鞭策大家就一定要去做
對
然後我們這些就是吃雞排
就不要咧
為什麼一定要
好奇怪哦
就是這樣子
你演的好真實哦
這樣我突然覺得我
我才是那個最機歪的角色
不會不會不會
因為我們團也是這樣
就我先生就是團長
他就是長這樣
他就是規定大家什麼時候要做
我們每個禮拜都要練團
就是即使我們大家工作這麼忙
每個禮拜都要練團
贊
然後時間都是固定下來這樣
然後可是
弄什麼東西他就是
一直會
就是他會有
因為我們每天
每個禮拜就是開完會之後
就會
待辦事項
待辦事項十幾項
然後就開始交代誰要做什麼
然後就跟
就跟凱翔一樣嘛
對對對
然後我們就是會有這種
就是像我們這種很屁的
為什麼一定要做這個
好奇怪哦
為什麼一定要這樣
這樣很沒有創意耶
我記得那時候訪談的時候
剛開始對訪談他很盯驚
他就覺得要寫逐字稿
因為我們
我們的專輯
還有
因為他會很多國外的樂團
會寫到
臺灣的文化歷史
他覺得不能講錯
年代什麼一定要講對
然後他是那種會為了這個
去看什麼杜魯門圖書館裡面
看電報那一種的
所以他就是非常非常嚴謹
那我就說這種東西
我說笑死
誰在
笑死
誰在寫組逐字稿啊
誰
我說連訪綱我都不要
然後我就很P嘛
嗯
然後他就說
那你回答看看啊
然後我就
隨便就講了十分鐘
他說那你講
然後我就
就是
真的耶
就會
就會像你這樣子
就是很自由
嗯
然後像我看你彈的東西
跟你在
那個對音樂的那個投入程度
就是越彈性越有空間
然後越讓你
譬如說可以喝酒
可以幹嘛
你的表演其實
嗯
那個精彩度是
沒有辦法複製跟替代
對我覺得像你剛剛說
你跟你先生
就是我就覺得
跟我跟格格好像
對所以我看到你
你們吵架
你要不要多講一點
你們那時候在
就是一起
就是玩團的時候的那個
就是開心的跟困難的
對因為我跟格格的個性就是
的確就像你看到的那樣子
然後
像凱翔就是上臺
我們會有talking嘛
他也是會寫逐字稿的
不知道
對然後
就是上臺然後他就會
像念稿一樣的
就是寫出他覺得
一定要傳達的話
然後
我的話都是
我上臺前大概想一個
我會講的主題
然後
上臺之後就任意的講這樣
然後我覺得
真的是
好壞都有欸
就是這兩種個性的人其實
雖然會摩擦很多
但是我覺得很適合當工作夥伴
真的
因為他是會
他會為整個氣氛就是
帶來不一樣的
就是個性
對
對然後
呃像凱翔他可能
出國的時候他都會想要
跟大家介紹臺灣
所以他很認真的寫了一份講稿
就是說臺灣的地理位置在哪裡
然後人口大概多少
然後我們
都要當一年的兵
所以我現在
就是很慶幸我可以拿著吉他
而不是步槍
就是像這個
講稿他是
寫好了之後
他每一場都講
就我會覺得他很像在貫徹一個
就是很像是那個教主
然後對不對
就是把這些
對對宣揚他想要的理念
傳道士的感覺
對然後我常常都是
喔我們今天什麼周邊
還沒有賣完是不是
然後我就說
就在臺上都是負責跟大家講說
請大家要記得要買什麼周邊喔
然後
呃我們三個團員
各自是誰誰誰誰
然後負責什麼工作
就是我就會
講一些比較輕鬆的事情
因為我知道
如果凱翔是嚴肅組的
我也變嚴肅組的
那這個團真的是
真的
大家去看就想說
我是來聽一場演講的
就會比較辛苦
但是凱翔這樣子的人的存在
的確也很重要
因為他反而就把那個邊界框起來
你的自由發揮好像就比較可以
知道
欸怎麼樣不會太超過
因為反正他會框起來
我覺得我跟鼓手嘉欽都是
越長大就是
越感謝凱翔的存在
因為其實他是真正讓
團務推進的人
就是
我們不是那種
市場很大的團
但是我們一直在做
我們自己想做的事
然後
我們每個月都有固定的薪水
就是我覺得光是達到這兩件事
我就覺得我人生無憾
就是
對我
因為我沒有想要賺大錢
但是我竟然可以做
我喜歡的事情
然後有穩定的薪水
然後
我們回頭看
就是其實都是凱翔一步一步的
規劃出來的
就是他會
寫很多的計劃
然後
他會知道我們想做什麼事情
但是我們沒有
這個預算的時候
我們要從哪裡想辦法去
找錢出來
然後他也會很明確的跟我們說
好那我們
2025要休團一年
所以我們2024要賺
2025一整年的錢
所以我們就必須要接幾場商演
這樣我們明年就可以放假
就是他會給我們很明確的目標
所以我們在演
例如說
其實臺下根本都不是我們樂迷
就是那種
會比較沮喪的表演的時候
我心裡就會有一個意志力
就是說我在
為我的
放假
對就是
我就會
還是會很感謝臺下的樂迷
因為他們讓我們可以有這個收入
就是我覺得
因為凱翔的這些規劃
所以在
我在玩團的路上
照理說
以我的個性可能會是
很不想要演商業演出
或者是什麼都會很排斥
但就是因為我知道
那個東西會換得
我們可以繼續玩這個團
所以就是
反而就會進行得蠻順利的
嗯
我覺得他在這件事情上
就是非常厲害
大家就是因為好玩
才會來玩團啦
所以才叫玩團啦
嗯
不然大家有那麼多計劃
不是
就會
心就會
那個火會滅掉
可是有些事情
你要讓他可以往前推進
你又需要那個計劃
嗯
所以我們後來討論好幾個樂團
都發現
就是每個團都有一個
這麼討人厭的人
但是他卻是裡面最重要
最不可或缺
因為當這個樂團想要去
那個看不到的風景的時候
是這個人他可以
做到這件事
對啊
所以我跟嘉欽現在
對凱翔就是都會
有在感謝他
嗯
因為我覺得其實中間有一度
會有那種感覺就是
啊凱翔做的這些規劃好像
剝奪掉我的一些自由
什麼就是
比較明確的例子應該就是他
2024 的那個世界巡迴
他跟每一個國家的廠牌
都是簽好合約寫明我只能喝兩瓶
有，我有看到你寫的那個
對然後
我就覺得哇
太瘋了吧
但是因為我完全記得
我以前做過什麼蠢事
所以我就也沒有辦法反駁
但是我就會覺得
哇
張凱翔你真的是
真的把所有點都挑出來欸
就是你所有事情都是明著做欸
對啊，還沒考慮一下就寫出來了欸
對因為那些廠牌都還沒認識我
就知道我是個酒鬼欸
就是我覺得
喔好丟臉喔這樣
結果到現場就發現超有用
因為他們真的都只給我兩瓶
哈哈哈哈
所以我就是
那一整年的巡迴真的就無事終了
就是
都沒有酒醉
然後也沒有因為喝太多
然後臺上
就是在大談闊論什麼的
嗯
所以就是
我覺得我對凱翔的態度
在這一方面有一點像是
以前從很排斥
然後到現在有點像感謝爸媽
把我栽培
對就是逼我要念書什麼的
我才能考上哪裡的那種
的那種心情在
就是稍微會膜拜他
但是如果有時候凱翔提出來的
意見
對我們來說如果真的太壓迫的話
其實現在都還是會溝通協商
對
完全理解你說的這個
就是像我上臺不是會喝酒嗎
雖然我們有說
這可能是個問題
但是
也不是問題啦
就是你太紓壓的方法
但只有這個方法有點可惜
對我就是
我們在找別的方法
但是我就是
甚至我自己在練習的時候
我就會預設我在
臺上是會喝酒的
所以我不可能像我在練團的時候
這麼的
可以這麼專注
是
所以我
其實在
自己在家練習的時候
我都會再做另外一件事情
然後讓我知道
大概注意力就是跟我喝酒之後
差不多
對
然後那樣的狀況下
不會彈錯的話
我在臺上才不會彈錯
嗯
對因為我平常如果認真練
但是我上臺總是灌一瓶之後
就開始忙掉的話
那個
狀態就不一樣
所以
就是
我覺得好像都會為了臺上
的表演去著想
然後來調整
我
平常練習到底要怎麼練習
很厲害耶
但我
我就想說
這好像就是你的天份
那對你哥來說
看到你那樣的時候
有時候會不會有一點
因為我記得在紀錄片裡
就有講到你哥看到你那邊
什麼一邊看漫畫
對一邊
對對對對
他就很氣
沒有那個就不禮貌
哈哈
那個就不是我說的這個
我講的這個是我自己在家裡的時候
喔在家裡
嗯
對但是我以前
我們剛搬回高雄的時候
我覺得我對於玩樂團
我覺得玩樂團這個玩這個字
真的是害慘大家耶
真的
其實我覺得如果不是這個動詞的話
大家會不會比較
其實比較認真看的
因為大家就會想像說
玩樂團好像就要很輕鬆啊
對
很舒壓
很愉快啊
但是就是你如果要做為職業的話
其實就不是
然後
很痛
對我那時候剛回高雄的時候還
觀念還沒轉過來
所以其實我樂團都很不認真
所以才會被他罵
哈哈
但我覺得就算是業餘
因為像我們是業餘
但是就算是業餘
只要你有考慮要出專輯
你有考慮要出國表演
其實那些壓力就
因為那個出國表演真的是
非常
而且我有看你們2023是
嗯
是2023還是2024
有60場
60場
對對對對
對對對40幾場
嗯嗯
哇
就是你們
那個時候是
怎麼做到這件事
因為
很驚人欸
而且
而且體力撐一整年欸
嗯
我覺得
我們這一次
就是2024的那個世界巡迴其實
我覺得超開心的
就我覺得安排得很好
嗯
然後那個安排是
我們剛出來的時候其實就
有一些role model在參考
然後我們很喜歡的樂團是
日本的Toe
就Toe
怎麼了
我很喜歡這個樂團
我那時候第一次聽你們的歌的時候
我就一直覺得你們的歌
讓我想到
一個我聽過的樂團
但是我一直想不起來
因為那個Toe是我
就是比較
比較研究所那個時候很喜歡
很常聽
你下一句話我就
對對對
我們超級喜歡它
然後
超喜歡
我們那時候其實就是
在我們大學的時候
他們就已經在世界上巡迴了
所以我們有一個很棒的參考
就是我們要去哪一個國家的時候
就會去聯繫他們的廠牌
哦
因為我們會知道
那是同一個樂風的東西
嗯
所以我覺得
前輩的力量總是
很偉大的
就是其實它
每一個資訊都寫在那些DVD後面
那就是看我們這些
後面的後輩
怎麼去找到這個軌跡
好棒哦
因為那時候我們知道在臺灣就是
會出國的那時候可能就是閃靈
這樣
可是
我們知道我們的風格不太一樣
所以像他們會去的國家
搞不好不一定喜歡我們這種音樂
所以我們後來其實反而是
從日本團的路線去找到
然後
所以才簽了
日本的經紀人跟美國的廠牌
大概都是這樣的路徑去認識的
好酷哦
而且我發現一件事情就是
我記得紀錄片裡面有講
你們是不同的國家
就有一個不同的經紀廠牌的人
然後你們就有很多對口
對
誰對呀
呃
要看欸
像日本是
直接跟我們對
嗯
然後
呃
美國的那個Top 12 Records
我們有找一個臺灣的女生
因為她是之前長期住在美國
所以她的英文使用會比我們好很多
嗯
對
然後
呃
其他的其實都是寄信這樣子
對
然後
我們現在也有在臺灣找行政的廠牌幫助我們
哦
所以就是因為
切得很細
我們就是
不是在臺灣有一個大公司
然後他幫我們做全世界的事
而是我們把
呃
自己的廠牌全部分散在當地嘛
那這樣的好處就是
我們其實真的就是會得到
當地的音樂節或什麼樣的資源
很到位
對對對
然後
我剛剛說我們跟
日本經紀人是直接聯繫的原因
就是因為
在他心中他想要把大象體操當成
Local Band在做
對
他很希望就是
日本的音樂圈在想說
要辦什麼音樂節呀
的時候會想到要找大象體操
就是他想要做到那個程度
所以
我們每次發片或什麼
其實
日本都會是我們很重視的一個市場
欸 我想問一個問題
因為這樣子你們等於是
其實也有蠻多事情還是自己去處理
對對對
那
因為你們其實看起來日文英文都很好
所以是有特別為了這件事情去練
哦
呃
凱翔的話其實一直英文都還不錯
嗯
然後我的話是大學的時候有修兩年的日文
然後知道自己要開始使用之後也都會
請家教上課
嗯
對但是
我的上課比較沒有壓力
只希望維持一個語感
我甚至有跟我們日本經紀人討論欸
就是像外國人的日文才是
外國團呀
對 才是外國團
對 真的
而且我發現你有寫日文歌詞
日文歌詞是跟日本歌手合作的
所以是他們寫的
我覺得好適合喔
就是那個歌詞寫的好適合你們的歌
就是我那時候聽他的那個原文的那個東西
我覺得好贊喔
所以我就覺得
好喜歡
對啊對啊對啊 謝謝
就是整個感覺非常棒
所以
話說回來
那你們誰
就是如果必須由你們自己處理的時候
是誰比較主要回那個信啊
我們團其實有分任務欸
喔真的喔 就是我是宣傳組的
嗯
然後嘉欽是周邊跟海外行政組的
然後凱翔是預算規劃
跟
什麼組
不知道
他就是在無限疊加上去的組
所以
呃宣傳的事情窗口就是跟我對
周邊跟海外的事情窗口就是跟嘉欽對
然後跟預算或者是補助有關的就是凱翔負責
喔原來如此
對啊如果是接活動的話
我們現在就是有一個幫忙的
嗯
廠牌
對
那我想要回過頭來問那個
我覺得我看的時候覺得最
最多情緒誘發
對對對
當然不是痛苦
但是就覺得很感同身受
就是好能理解那個狀況
就是怎麼會發生到需要三個人去討論
就是
這個團的存亡
嗯
然後那個是
當然是巡迴之前
但我有點忘記是幾年的時候
發
就是你們成團幾年的時候發生的事情
那個好像是2023 年初吧
喔就是
結束
喔是啊
結束就去巡迴這樣子
對對對對
就是那個時候
其實我覺得我們那次的爭執的點
沒有很大
但是我覺得很核心
喔
是怎麼了
好
就是大象其實後來一直在發展的狀況下
就是我們會去跟劇場合作啊
然後
呃會出國演出
然後因為我們的路線比較特殊
然後音樂風格上也比較特殊
所以其實我們會跟臺灣的樂團圈
越來越遠
不太熟
對但是
我覺得很有趣的是
我自己身邊有很多樂團的朋友
對
所以我會知道就是
大家有時候會一起表演啊
或者是
就是辦那種
拼盤型的演出
啊對對對對
然後有幾個好朋友這樣
我其實就很羨慕
嗯
對然後
到後期我們真的越來越少就是跟
臺灣的樂團一起演出
嗯
然後我有一次在跟那個
一個團叫傷心鬱絕
就我們的
我跟他們吉他手聊天時就說
還是我們一起來辦一個演出這樣
然後我們那時候就
有在臺北Legacy就辦了這演出
然後也賣得很好
但是
因為要演出就要規劃
然後我有知道就是對於
凱翔來說就是
他現在對於這種
好像比較像是玩的性質的
事情他會已經沒有那麼熱衷了
所以我就說那這整場
就當作你接到一個商演
然後是
事情都我來對
嗯
這樣
然後就
我們那次就真的是
我就把
預算表什麼寫出來
然後去訂場地
然後
另外一個團就可能負責
一些事務這樣
然後就順利的辦完
還算順利
後來我就
我們有
其實有三個團
然後在聊天就說
哇那天真的好開心哦
要不要來辦個高雄場
嗯
我那時候也正在興頭上
我就去跟我的團員提案
結果就是
凱翔就有點像是
馬上交了一個冷水
有點類似說
讓你做臺北場已經是
我個人的極限
對對對
就是我把
我讓你做一個風險這麼高的事情
因為對他來說
其實
那樣有很多風險
就是包含我
我其實不確定票房
嗯
然後以及會不會消耗掉我們
以後自己專場的
樂迷期待
那個人
就是那都要
評估的嘛
但是我就是想要好玩
我就是打破這一切的
規矩這樣子
然後我還想要辦高雄場
然後對他來說就是有點
他就會
理智斷線這樣子
對然後我覺得這個就
其實很牽扯到
我跟凱翔看待樂團是
用很不一樣的視角
嗯
就是對我來說
我對於那個玩這個字
就還蠻重視的
嗯
就是我會覺得
就是除了藝術方面的追求
我還是希望跟
臺灣的
玩團的大家有一個交流
對然後我覺得凱翔是他真的
眼光真的很專注的放在他的追求上面
然後像這樣的
事情對他來說就比較像是
娛樂性節目
不知道
就是對他來說意味不明啊
嗯
我覺得聽起來就是你們看待
樂團這件事的看法不太一樣
就是你覺得
樂團好玩又可以糊口
這樣就很棒了
但是凱翔是把它當成一個事業在經營
對對對，就是要可以結婚買房
然後可以就是
也可以發展自己想要的
自我實現的這一塊
對對對
所以我就覺得你們的表演非常多元
還有那種沉浸式劇場演出啊
嗯
那個真的很贊欸
那我覺得
我覺得那真的很讚！
而且我覺得樂團可以做這個東西真的超棒的
但是我覺得這的確就是兩難的地方
當你們的目標有一點
不一樣的時候
不一樣的時候，嗯
然後再加上溝通的方式
因為看起來好像在那個時候
溝通的方式就更容易變成
欸，你要是不同意我的意見
是不是就等於否定我這個人
或是情緒上的東西比較難消化
對就蠻激烈的
就是我後來覺得
確實我們在經營樂團的想法上
想法上有很多的分歧
嗯
但我並不覺得這個分歧
是不能被解決的
例如說
我有這樣的用意
而且我也認為這樣可以幫助
大象在臺灣還是能紮根
嗯
在這個場景裡也還能被看見
那我提出這個需求
然後我可能說
那我們一年可能有一個額度
就是
嗯
辦一次這樣的演出就好
然後都是我來負責
我覺得其實
這樣的溝通方式會比較適合
我們現在的年紀跟
要怎麼跟凱翔溝通/相處
就是而不是說
我想怎樣
就是我覺得
凱翔現在的狀況可能就是
我如果
太隨意的講出
一句話他
會有點反彈
因為他會覺得已經是工作了
欸我覺得這個東西很有趣
因為我後來有研究一件事
就是我們那時候
決定要去日本巡迴的時候
然後本來我們那時候是覺得
好像不太可能
嗯
後來就是我們鼓手就去
聯繫
後來就成了
嗯
然後成了之後
就是演得也很開心
嗯
在那個過程之中
我後來發現一件
蠻重要的事情
就是當我們有一些覺得說
為什麼一定要這樣
這樣也可以啊
有那麼嚴重嗎
沒關係啊
嗯
我發現他在那個時候
他的那個情緒的那個
他的那個情緒的容納值很低啊
就是很容易一下就滿
然後就爆炸
嗯
然後後來我才發現
他好像把非常非常多的事情
都扛在手上
然後沒有交給我們做
嗯
或是他覺得交給我們做
他不能放心
所以最終那些事情
全部都在他手上
嗯
然後他就很容易會爆炸
如果這一切都是這樣
他
他最好的方式就是
不能讓他失控
所以他是控制那個人
嗯
因為另外兩個人
看起來不太能做控制這件事情
對
然後我覺得如果
如果不是那麼知道
他扛多少東西
然後
不小心說了一句什麼
對對對對
但我覺得這個也很麻煩
因為我後來
對
因為我後來幾次
有發生那種
就是也是會發生那種
我先生就說
好啊那算了
我都不要做
就這種
然後我就想說
幹嘛要講這種話呢
你又沒辦法不做
就是我就會很奇怪這樣想
但是我就覺得他很生氣
嗯
然後後來我就發現
我就跟他說你要不要考慮
有些事情你就交出去
沒有做得那麼好也沒有關係
反正不會有那麼糟糕的結果
嗯
就
可以交出去的
你就先交出去
然後
會讓你跟大家的相處
不會這麼的
硬
因為我覺得
我們曾經有一段時間
那個練團氣氛
嗯
不聊天的
就是練團
嗯
然後就很像是那個
打卡上班有沒有
然後練練練練
大家練完
然後哪裡要調整
然後就下班
嗯
然後我覺得真的是去巡迴之後
大家感情才變得比較好
然後會講很多543
然後巡迴一直吵架啊
嗯
大家都一直吵啊
然後吵回來之後
就是吵回來還忍得下去
就是就像那個蜜月旅行
回來還沒有離婚
這個婚姻就還可以繼續下去
對對對
我不知道你們有沒有這樣的經驗
有欸
我覺得我們持續
都一直在溝通
就是我覺得我們團可能是
我自己身邊
的
就是朋友裡面
這樣聽起來應該是
最常在討論
事情的人
我們習慣把事情講出來
很棒欸
對
但是
它就是要花很多時間
嗯
對
然後
我是很樂於花這個時間的
但是
我覺得
現在其實有一種
好像問題永遠都不會有討論完的一天
嗯
就是我不能把它當成
會有一個終點
感覺這應該是一個
永遠都要進行的
因為大家都在變動嘛
對對對
因為人生的
階段也是
對
然後心境上也是
所以
剛剛講的就是說
例如說凱翔是一個
扛了很多責任的人
那他現在因為
他也有結婚生小孩了
那
他可能覺得
已經快要
負荷不了
那到底
哪一些東西可以再交出來
或者是
他扛的那些東西
可不可以支付他額外的費用
讓他覺得整個是平衡的
因為我覺得
有時候
他可能其實是想做的
但是他內心覺得
他沒有得到應有的回饋
就是我覺得如果問題是那個的話
那應該是想辦法去
讓他覺得
一切是對得起來的
因為
一旦有一個人是這樣的話
他看別人可能很容易不順眼
嗯
但是我覺得要改變的其實
不一定是別人
有可能是要改變他的
例如說不管是薪資狀況
或者是工作的份量
嗯
對 因為通常應該都是那個
看不順眼別人的人
他可能
主動去
接了一些
事情
然後他下不了臺
就是他的個性可能也會讓自己下不了臺
對
對 所以
因為我有一陣子會蠻
反過來就是
想說是不是我的錯
就是是不是我太廢了
或者是
因為我是如果我不想接的事情我就
我就不會做這樣
但是我後來覺得
不行我覺得我現在這樣
我很喜歡我自己這樣
所以我不能因為
他的
情緒
嗯
然後也去背
然後讓我變得跟他一樣
就我覺得這樣好像不會變好
嗯
感覺應該是他那邊要放下
要放下
嗯
我覺得你們講到一個東西
我覺得非常有趣
就是
在越有情緒的時候
他們越會只跟你講事情
嗯
然後你會
你那時候在溝通的時候
你就覺得離他們很遠
對
他們就越來越用事情的方式
去跟你溝通
然後你就會忍不住想
就是怎麼可以我一個人在下面
要來大家都要下來
然後就把大家全部一起拖下來
對 然後就把大家全部一起拖下來
因為我覺得
長大之後
我遇到的溝通上的問題都是這種
就是
呃
例如說
我今天問我的團員說
欸今天有一個表演的邀約
你們要不要接這樣
然後
我覺得我得到的答案都不會是真心話
就是
那他們會怎麼回答你
就有點像是
喔凱婷我們覺得就是
這個期間應該要寫歌
所以
不適合接這個表演
然後我就會覺得很奇怪
可是明明就接了另外一個
嗯
那這個怎麼不能接
然後我就是要問問問到很後來才會發現說
喔其實是因為上次我們在這個活動演出的時候
有什麼不好的回憶
所以
我有PTSD我不想接
就是
我其實如果是一開始得到的就是這個答案的話
我就
我就會說
喔好那我們就不要接
但是
我覺得大人的溝通方式常常是提出一個
我聽不懂的
欸其實我覺得這不一定是大人的溝通方式
我後來發現這還蠻像是有很多很害怕衝突的男性
的溝通方式
嗯
就是
一般人好像有時候不會那麼有
很安心的感覺
就直接講出
這個東西我
我不要
是因為我不行
對
所以我們好像還在抓一個
距離就是
樂團的夥伴到底是
我們是同事還是我們是夥伴
因為我覺得如果我是同事
我現在都會想像
如果我是在一個
假設書店工作好了
我的同事跟我講什麼理由
所以他不能做什麼
其實我不會在乎欸
嗯
就是
喔好
你的意思其實就是你要請假
或者是你的意思就是怎樣
就
理由其實
沒有那麼重要
但是我覺得樂團就是因為
夥伴的那個性質很重
所以
我好像
必須要知道你在想什麼
對因為
太緊密了
我覺得我可以懂
對但是
我覺得
這個線我一直在抓
就是
我是不是也應該要放下
就是即使我聽起來
好像不是真心話
或者是他只是有用一個表面的理由來搪塞的時候
我是不是就放過就算了
我覺得這真的好難喔
就算我是心理師
我也覺得這個問題好難
說真的
就是
像你們那邊也是男生比較多嘛
嗯
然後我們這邊是有
4、5個都是男生
我一個女生
而且因為大家都是社畜
都有在外面工作過
所以溝通方式真的是一個就是
非常溫良恭儉讓
很適合就是去上班會講的
就是社會化的大人會講的話
就是社會化的大人會講的話 有被磨練過
對對對
然後有的時候我就會覺得
但是明明那個情緒我聽就有嘛
嗯
為什麼不直接把這個東西講出來
然後我就是
我也是會去丟炸彈的那個人
我就是
我也是那種會
會去直接就是說
欸你這怎樣怎樣
我覺得你這樣不行
我也是直接會講這樣的人
可是蠻好玩的事情是
我在其他的工作領域不是這樣的
我就只覺得
我只對樂團這樣
就連我自己的諮商所
我的好朋友
我都不會這樣跟他們講話
可是我只對樂團這樣
而且我覺得那個
斷線的狀況
理智前額葉那時候完全不會工作
嗯
就是都是直接出去
然後就丟炸彈，拉著大家一起死
就那種感覺很強欸
對就是
我覺得
我不知道為什麼
就是有一種毀滅性的
希望大家誠實
我覺得這個東西好像真的是
我們跟這些團員有過
就是共患難
然後有過很多經驗的時候
會有一種
我把你放在這麼親密的位置
嗯
你們沒有把我放在那麼親密的位置
你們是想要跟我用比較遠的位置去互動
所以我覺得那個失落
我說我啦
嗯
我覺得那個失落感是在的
哦
我會有那個失落感
我會覺得說
但明明我
為什麼不能跟我直接講
嗯
明明我是可以直接講的人
但是如果我把情緒丟出來
他們可能就會覺得說
你看
沒有直接講就這樣了
直接講還會
還會嗎
但是
所以我覺得我年輕的時候
也會遇到很多這樣的狀況
嗯
那後來就是也是慢慢練習
就是我會直接講
就是我可能就會直接講事情說
哦
我說
欸
可是那你們也接了哪個表演
還是你們有什麼考量
可能要再講清楚一點
讓我知道
不然我不懂
嗯
就是我可能會講得這麼清楚
就我還是直
但是沒有那麼多情緒
嗯
奇怪那個可以接這個不能接
都你們在講
就不是用直問的
是提出疑問
對對對
然後後來發現這些男生們
我這樣子他們比較接得住
嗯
對對對
然後他們就覺得
不用處理那麼多情緒
對因為我覺得好像
其實
把情緒拿掉很重要欸
就是我
就是我一定知道我有情緒
然後我也接受我這個情緒
但是不代表
我的團員就一定要接受我的情緒
他們應該要接受到的是我
過濾完我自己的情緒之後
我真正的疑問
我覺得
現在就會
希望我可以做到的是這個
不然的話
因為像在紀錄片裡面
嘉欽
也有說
他說
凱婷這樣的方式
我跟凱翔就是
都沒有辦法承受太多次
嗯
就是可能太激烈了這樣子
對
就是我覺得在跟
一群人一起合作
然後工作
然後甚至到感情很深厚的時候
我覺得真的會有我們
對關係的期待的那個落差
然後要怎麼樣去調整到我們兩邊
我們三邊都可以接受的狀況
就比如說像
有些人的習慣
就是不喜歡衝突
不喜歡消化這麼多情緒
嗯
然後所以對他來說
真實不是最重要的
大家不起衝突才是最重要的
哇
我們團
好特別的人
欸有很多人這樣啊
我在猜嘉欽就是這樣啊
就是
真實的東西我們可以晚點再講
但是我們不要起衝突
讓關係破裂
嗯
這件事情是最重要
對他來講這件事情絕對是最重要
因為我可能承受不起別人的情緒
哦
然後對有些人來說
因為我在猜
嘉欽說不定跟我一樣是焦慮依附
偏焦慮依附的人
情緒的容納度
就是面對那個巨大的情緒的狀態
比較大
比較容易
嗯
比較可以承受衝突啊什麼
原因是因為我們自己內在情緒
起伏就很大
對
不會舒服
但是我們不會覺得說
哦這樣衝突我們關係就會斷裂
嗯
我會覺得
講清楚講開就沒事了
嗯
但是對很多比較逃避依附的人來說
就是很多男性
或是像
像凱翔啊
嘉欽這種可能
性格上是比較希望把事情做好
不要把重心放那麼多在情緒的人
嗯
也都會覺得要把情緒收好
所以不要讓情緒造成別人的困擾
嗯
不要讓情緒造成我們之間的衝突
就可能會是他們的
第一要務
因為這樣子才可以把事情講清楚
但沒情緒這個狀態
又會讓你覺得說
我不知道你們的狀態
嗯
我就會很慌張
我就會更追
所以他那個互動模式就很容易會發生這樣的結果
對
因為我們真的相處太久了
所以勢必也要解決就是這樣的狀況
然後
我們現在好像有產生一個模式就是
我們如果有一個事情
有一個 issue 知道
應該會吵架
我們就會先說
那今天只能各自發表對這個議題的意見
但不能討論
然後要到三天後
我們再來討論
然後決定結果
決定結果的方式是
只要有一個人不要
那就不要
例如說一個活動
那有一些活動或者是說提案可能是
只要有一個人說好
就做
所以每次還不一樣
哈哈哈哈
就有不同標準這樣子
但是我覺得這個
就是我因為我在紀錄片有看到
目睹那個過程
嗯
我覺得超成熟的耶
就是因為我那時候看你們一開始
坐下來第一句話就說
我們今天就是
每個人可以有一個小時
然後對那時候我看到
說有一個小時
我想說等一下一個三個小時
紀錄片有多長
所以我還要再看三個小時
大家的心得分享
那一段真的很精彩
大家一定要去看
然後剪得很好
然後就是大家就講自己的心情
然後跟感受
然後呢
就是各自講完
然後就特別講說
不能打斷
就是凱翔有特別講不能打斷
我覺得這是一個超成熟的
溝通模式是因為
我們至少都有聽到對方講什麼
對
我也至少把我的東西講出來
然後這些東西
我需要時間消化
嗯
然後等我時間消化
我的情緒一定會比較下降
對
啊情緒下降前額葉就會有功能
就可以做判斷
我們常常在情緒上的判斷
跟在情緒下降的判斷會不一樣
確實
對
真的會不一樣
絕對會不一樣
這個前額葉它還是有功能
所以
我覺得這個做法好棒哦
你們怎麼
怎麼有辦法想出這個方法啊
我自己覺得
這個方法真的其實
大家都可以試著用用看
因為我覺得連家庭
對
都很適合的原因是
我覺得像
假設一個家庭
然後都是爸爸媽媽
比較常在跟小孩子講話
但是你規定
說
我們今天這四個人
兩個大人兩個小孩
都有一個小時
我覺得對於大人來說也會超衝擊
就是你
聽你的小孩
完整的傳達一個小時的事情
而且你不能像以前那樣就說
妹妹不是
我跟你講媽媽以前就是
就
你知道就是
因為我們太習慣打斷別人的
我覺得只要沒有說好
一定會有打斷
我覺得我們可以去觀察這件事
因為真的一定就是會打斷
所以
要讓大家可以
暢談自己的想法
我覺得就是要先設立這個規則
我們那一次
為了解決我們即將要解散的
這個
狀況
所以我們那一個小時真的非常的珍貴
因為我們知道
大家現在情緒都很滿
如果沒有規定的話
完蛋
就是又會吵起來
所以我覺得這個方法真的是超級棒
就是
其實你們那時候自己就在幫自己做
團體諮商
唉
哈哈
我那時候看凱翔那個書
桌上有很多那種情緒的工具書
哈哈
我想他可能有翻出來參考一下
對
對那我最後想問一個問題哦
就是因為後來你們有去做團體諮商
你們做了多久
然後你覺得對你的幫助是什麼
因為我們是去年有休團一段時間嘛
然後我們在前期的時候有做三次
然後
那三次
其實我們
沒有
我們三個人都沒有個人諮商的經驗
然後也沒有伴侶諮商的經驗
所以對我們來說
我們也是抱持著一個完全未知的狀態
就是去約的
然後甚至那個諮商的診所也告訴我們說
哦我們也沒有做過什麼樂團諮商
那不然我們就是來試試看
那你們如果覺得做完之後好像沒什麼用的話
那也沒關係
就試試看
所以我們第一次的時候就是三個人進到那邊
然後就
醫師就坐在舒服的沙發
然後我們也都坐在舒服的沙發上
然後我覺得那次對我來說是一個很震撼的經驗
就是
我們三個人內部其實是
很大量在溝通的人
但是我們從來沒有試過是把
團裡的問題要講給
一個完全
基本上連樂團是什麼都不知道的人
我們光是為了講我們的問題在哪裡
我就聽到
凱翔或嘉欽講出了我從來沒有聽過的話
所以我覺得
非常驚人
嗯
對
就是
竟然有一個人在那裡
然後他在傾聽你們三個的時候
我們
突然那個
講話的對象不再是彼此
我覺得這件事情超級重要
就是
以一個旁觀者的方式聽到他覺得
我有什麼問題的時候
那會比他直接跟我講我有什麼問題
來的突然變得客觀很多
嗯
我就想說
對我就是這樣
我就是這麼糟糕
諮商師都還不用跟我討論
我就已經完全覺得
天啊我要反省
嗯
然後真的好酷
是一個很特別的經驗
對
然後因為像佳欣她就為了要跟諮商師介紹
我們是什麼樂手
然後她就說
我是一個鼓手
然後
其實在團裡面我覺得
自己在編曲
或者是甚至是形象上
我都沒有辦法幫助到團很多
我對這件事情一直
覺得自己有所虧欠
所以想要拿其他的努力來補
什麼什麼
她在講的時候我就是整個就是
好難過哦
對我們三個都有
各自都有哭
那明明她
她打得很好
她為什麼要這麼想
就是我覺得
我從來沒有聽過欸
對啊
覺得怎麼會這麼想呢
她是靈魂欸
怎麼會這樣想呢
就是
就是鼓
跟貝斯
是靈魂欸
怎麼會覺得自己
哇
然後因為我跟凱翔都是那種
意見很多的人
所以
我們反而覺得有時候
嘉欽是
她的角色是
幫我們拉住一些
其實無法執行的事情
是
然後
可是她竟然是覺得自己
總是
沒有在給想法什麼的
我就會覺得很驚訝
嗯
對
然後過程中凱翔可能也有
跟諮商師提出就是
他們那時候在
備孕啊
然後
要生產的一些
對家庭想像的焦慮
我覺得那時候就會
覺得
我們三個都
畢竟就是人類
然後我們會有
各個層面都會有不同的issue
然後
因此會影響到團
那現在就是
大家就是都講出來
然後
我覺得以後就會更
互相體諒
就是不會想要把對方
追到
死地這樣
因為我知道你最近在忙什麼
然後
就算了吧
我們不要再
真的真的真的
其實我覺得溝通順暢
真的有一個非常重要的關鍵是
我不知道你的狀況
嗯
我對於你這樣子做
我就會很生氣
嗯嗯
可是我知道你的狀況
甚至我知道這件事情沒有辦法
被執行
是因為你有困難
嗯
的時候
其實我們反而比較能夠
接受跟理解這件事情
沒錯
真的真的
然後我還有體會到第三個好處
第三個好處
就是
我們
很容易會是在開會
我們討論事情
就算今天是約好
要聊彼此的心情
可是
你一進到
那個諮商的診所
然後你知道說
這三個小時是要講自己的狀態
你會知道諮商是
不是來跟你開會的
所以我們就
終於不會再
每次都很焦慮自己是不是在
浪費時間聊心事
因為沒有
就是在這三個小時裡面
這個就是最重要的事
唉
我覺得現代人真的很可悲
真的
我覺得這很
這真的很重要
因為有時候我們團
在聊一些五四三的時候
我先是說
可以聊正事了嘛
可是其實
那一些互相瞭解彼此的狀態
情感的連結
我們能夠一起玩這個
一起
一起運作這個團
其實不就是因為這些感情嗎
對啊
所以我覺得真的
去諮商就是那三次
每一次我們都有跟諮商師聊不同的議題
然後都幫助
我覺得幫助很大
就是他提供我們後續
又回到我們這種開會狀態的時候
我們會有一個
前提的
認知
嗯
我覺得超棒，各位樂團
如果你們也有吵架的狀況
可以去做一下團體諮商
不要每次都靠喝酒
我跟你講
過35歲之後
你喝酒你又會脂肪肝啊
什麼東西
對
而且喝酒講的真心話
都是帶有攻擊性的
對啊
然後我都覺得
就是什麼酒後吐真言
啊你是不能白天的時候講是不是
就是
對對對
就大家我們可以就是
好好的就是讓我們的溝通變得更順暢
這個團體諮商對你們的幫助很大
我聽了也覺得很開心
呵呵呵
好啦
我覺得今天跟凱婷真的聊很多
然後
我覺得不小心我自己也講很多
因為我覺得這個我們也沒什麼機會
因為大家玩樂團不太會
就是
就
就是大家其實都是各自
在做各自的事情
對啦
見面的時候聊點垃圾話比較放鬆
對嘛
都嘛在講垃圾話
不然就講別的樂團八卦
才不要講自己樂團
或是講自己團員的壞話
對對對
講團員
那誰沒來就講他壞話
對但我們剛其實也講了不少
今天真的聊得非常非常開心
就是很感謝凱婷可以來上我們的節目
那大象體操的紀錄片 比夢境更真實
在2月6號
就會上映喔
對
那詳細的一些
影片的一些
就是要大家觀影的資訊
那去哪裡有上映等等
那我們會放在我們的資訊欄
請大家多多支持
非常非常好看
就算你沒玩樂團
你在看了你都會覺得很感動
謝謝
謝謝凱婷
謝謝大象體操
周慕姿放心說
我們下次見囉
掰掰